Counter Strike has a problem it's not
the rampant cheating the terrible
incline matchmaking or the abysmal tick
rate if the fact that some of the
biggest companies in the world aren't
interested in sponsoring your favorite
teams I know that doesn't sound like
much of a big deal to you but behind the
scenes it's an issue that's rockin the
CS world and one that's already caused
one of the biggest teams in the space to
pack their bags and move on
and if Counter Strike doesn't change
soon that problem could stunt the game's
growth at a crucial time so last year SK
gaming pulled out of counter-strike and
they haven't gone back in what's even
weirder is that before they let all
their players sign with the Immortals
own made in Brazil brand they had one of
the best teams in CS before June 2018 SK
gaming had a two-time major winning
roster on their payroll sure results
started to slip but they were still one
of the best rosters in the world and
they had a legion of Brazilian fans but
in June two years after signing that
team SK gaming let their contracts lapse
and let all the players go to MIB R and
for our purposes however that team
performed afterwards doesn't really
matter SK gaming one of the oldest
brands in esports 18 with a near
constant presence in CS is do that home
to hope it gave up on the game they
could have picked up another CS team but
instead they took their money and
invested in League of Legends with a new
permanent spot in the LEC according to
SK gaming's managing director Alexander
Muller that was because the organization
didn't really see a future encounters
direct we were asking ourselves will
they be this number one asset as they
have been mid-2016 till the end of 2017
again
and at some point we decided against it
we're not you know we're not saying it's
a bad team we just said that the team is
probably they hit that peak and it's
going to be very tough for them to
compete at the highest level again but
skill and trophies aren't the only
reasons SK didn't see their
new team is a strong asset going forward
they were also worried about how many
sponsors they could sell on
counter-strike in general it's also
connected to the new brands that we're
working with especially with the
sponsors Counter Strike is a is a more
problematic title than some people think
especially when it comes down to the
sponsorship market in Central Europe in
Germany a lot of companies actually have
a problem with the game it's a sixty
plus title and we have no problem in
working with and around it but for some
partners it is a sacrifice and they
might not want to do it as much as it
pains me to say it
counter-strike is a problematic game
it's a game in which you have to play as
terrorists wielding realistic weaponry
in order to kill counterterrorism
specialists and plant a bomb they'll
destroy anything from a city block to a
nuclear power plant look you and I both
know that just because you play a lot of
csgo doesn't mean you're gonna go around
and blow up a wagon and a European
caster but you can't deny that the
optics on csgo are pretty bad especially
considering the current political
situation the US and around the world it
doesn't matter what side of the
political spectrum you're on csgo just
kind of looks bad to a casual observer
who he's done by once on the news every
night and those outside observers have a
lot of money those sponsors that Muller
mentioned weren't interested in
counter-strike well he didn't name any
names but Deutsche Telekom and
mercedes-benz two huge companies didn't
sign on until after the organizational
left Counter Strike to get on their
League of Legends teams Jersey escape
aren't the only team that's had problems
in CS either over its life team
co-founder Marty's friends awoke says
that his organization also left CS due
in part to the sponsored issue
counter-strike is challenging to sell
the sponsors it is a first-person
shooter and it's a very explicit one
with the terrorism angle to it I hate
that that's the case it's a wonderful
game I loved watching it but it's the
facts of building sustainable business
right it's much easier to build a
sustainable business around a game like
overwatch or League of Legends or smite
or rocket League let's go with the most
extreme example right then a game where
it is about blowing something up look at
FC schalke the German soccer team got
into eSports in 2016 and their managing
director
timrai shirt said that csgo was not
something the club was interested in
flash force of 2019 and CS is bigger
than ever it's probably the biggest game
in the West in terms of viewership and
there's never been a better time to get
into the scene and yet research says
that FC schalke still wants nothing to
do with counter-strike the IPO cycle
that they won't be part of that that
business future games especially at the
end if you compare that to a lot of
political issues right now so shooters
multi-part right now and I also doubt
now this isn't to say that every single
non-endemic company the world doesn't
want to touch csgo astrology as OD team
wood has Honda there are plenty of
companies out there and there are even
some people out there that think that
the ones having trouble with selling
csgo sponsorships are just barking up
the wrong tree it's you know there's
market for everything you know there are
brands interested in in first-person
shooters there are a lot of brands I
know them I speak to them and there are
brands and those same brands may not be
as interested in hearthstone
and that's just the circle of life now
it is possible that all these teams are
going to the wrong people and you just
have to dig a little deeper to find the
right sponsor for your CST but the
problem still stands there are a limited
number of non-endemic sponsors who are
interested in Counter Strike and that is
a problem for the future of the game
csgo experienced a huge explosion in
popularity during 2015 and a viewership
has been on the rise ever since even
breaking records during the majors and
yet all the growth opportunities seem to
be going to other games right now look
at League of Legends right franchise in
North America Europe and China over the
last few years and is now bringing in
sponsorship from companies like State
Farm Kia and MasterCard the money is
going elsewhere and that's a big deal
csgo doesn't have these big leagues that
dominate the space which means that team
sponsorships are the place that
non-endemic scan a really invest their
money and several team owners
issues finding interested sponsors it
doesn't sound super exciting I know but
these sponsors are the ones putting up
the money that keeps leagues and
tournaments running and players paid and
as player salaries keep going up
non-endemic sponsors are only going to
become more important at the start of
this video I said the Counter Strike has
a problem and it's this if something
doesn't change about csgo the game's
eSports scene is not gonna keep growing
as fast as it has been over the last
couple of years player salaries could
start to stagnate tournaments could dry
up which would lead to viewership going
down and that's what leads to endemic
sponsors heading out to but it's not all
doom and gloom all kind of strike needs
is a change and it's a pretty small one
some people don't think the game needs
to change as much as these companies
attitudes do but others think that it's
counter-strike the need to shift and it
doesn't have to be a big one all you
need to do is drop the word terrorist
call it attack force of defense or red
side vs. blue sign it sounds ridiculous
but it works go look at Rainbow six a
game with just as much if not more
graphic violence and a realistic guns a
csgo but it hand waves all the
multiplayer way by calling it a training
simulator can restaurant pull it out
last time he was able to stick it gets
the coach a system how do these things
happen in these matches don't look down
and just on the range of that Claymore
that is definitely not the training
simulation but the game is on the rise
and the fact that teams can tell their
sponsors that their game doesn't involve
teams blowing up a nuclear power plant
means a lot but for the die-hard csgo
fan out there changing T and CT to
attack in the fence is basically
sacrilege I'm sure some of you are up in
arms in the comment section already but
if that doesn't change about the game
something has to or else counter-strike
is gonna have a lot more than just a
sponsor
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]